all right good afternoon everyone and
welcome to this meeting of cabinet uh do
we have any apologies for absence
Harry and councilor Kettle is running a
little late
thank you uh discloses of interest do we
have any disclosures of Interest
unit
um I might mention the fact that I am
chair of Ulster youth project and I
might mention that in what I want to say
if you don't mind I have been for about
10 years it's a constituted voluntary
body that's based in Ulster
thanks councilor junid any more
disclosures of Interest
no so in that case minutes are there is
everyone happy with the minutes from the
meeting held on the 6th of March
are there any comments on the minutes
if you insist
minute 633 line two
the word that should be the word who
and in the third paragraph the cabinet
it's written were advised it should be
the cabinet was advised but I didn't say
any of that
thank you councilor Harvey it's nice to
see consistency
uh right I'm going to
um
revise the agenda to take item five
insurance contract before item four on
the grounds at item four is counselor
kettles and he has not yet arrived
so uh councilor Harvey insurance
contract
thank you Mr chairman this is a very
standard sort of item where the object
the exercises to ensure that the council
receives best value for money
and therefore it's necessary that we put
out for tender our insurance
arrangements as set out in the paper the
intention is to review the whole lot on
the basis of a contract initially for
three years then with the option to
extend for two years and the option to
extend for a further two years I.E for
seven years in total this is a value for
money sort of exercise Good Housekeeping
the sort of thing that every Council
should be doing from time to time and
now it's our turn so I uh quite happy to
put forward the recommendations one two
and three as set out in the paper
so I have a second please
councilor shenton thank you
are are there any issues or comments
members of cabinet wish to make
I think this is an exceedingly routine
piece of business so in that case uh
members of cabinet are we happy with the
recommendations one two and three on
page 71.
thank you members of
so
moving slowly on
go to uh part C
what did you guys
in that case I will move to uh part C
issues arising from overview and
scrutiny councilor Crump sorry to uh
um bring this so far forward
thank you Mr chairman yeah not a problem
at all
um yep I've been scrutiny
um it was last meeting on the Friday's
just gone
um we've had a a challenge in last 12
months where we looked into several
issues and had some Lively debates and
discussions and I think the process has
been good and there's some definitely
some learning points and I think they've
been addressed by by officers and the
induction program particularly around
training in the same way that the
training we have for planning and
Regulatory so and I think that's going
to be addressed I think that's a wise
thing to do because sometimes I don't
think members have necessarily got the
scrutinizing skills that they need on
everyone scrutiny and I think if they're
going to do that job they need to do
properly and have they the resources and
they're trying to do so so I think
that's particularly Fair we had a
discussion from the portfolio councilor
Parry who did say she was saving the
best of last but obviously I couldn't
come about that in this exalted company
but uh
I'll leave it at that and again we spoke
about the the series serious once uh
Duty
um and again uh actually obviously
that's cancer Kettle wasn't I don't know
a little bit about that so I'm about to
speak on that a bit later if you you
require so thank you very much thank you
councilor Crump uh in that case I think
we will return to where item for the
series violence Duty
um the paper is there uh
yeah
so Mr Perks if you'd like to give a
brief introduction
if you carry on
sure uh thank you leader um the paper
that you have before you today at item
four is relating to a serious violence
Duty it's a new Duty that the council is
asked to sort of comply with
and the paper before you sort of sets
out the way that we intend to comply and
seek some sort of Delegation prostitute
um sign a partnership agreement which
has been drawn up in conjunction with
other authorities within Warwickshire in
the Warwickshire County Council
um it sets out the serious violence
strategy and how we would seek to
address that within Warwickshire sitting
beneath this will be uh an action plan
related to Stratford District at a later
date so what we're seeking today is
um an authority to sort of sign that
there's some recommendations to council
um it was discussed at the urban view in
scrutiny committee on Friday there were
a couple of concerns raised about
equality impact assessments and getting
those carried out we've taken some
advice from the teams that have been
carried out in respect of the strategy
and if we were to as and when we did the
Stratford action plan we'll pick up that
point at that time we have um Sam
Islamic at the back who's closer to this
time if you've got any specific
questions or counselor kettles now in
the room
um so here's a good knowledge of it as
well I'll leave it at that
counselor kettles do you wish to make
any comments uh no I think
um the deputy chief executive has
covered everything I would have said
um it's um it's yet another
um tasks picked up by the community
safety team
um and regrettable it's one that no
doubt will keep us very busy in the
fourth coming years as we go ahead
um it's effectively introducing the same
measures for domestic homicide
to and what we have to do for that in
relation to
um
serious and violence
crime
um it has been um led by the County
Council and I see the portfolio holder
for that is in fact sitting in the room
who happens to be our own chairman of
our osc
um so it will be led by the county but
the
the tasks will be our own tasks that we
have to we will have to deliver on
we'll just observe councilor Kettle that
domestic homicide reviews do involve
quite a bit of work having chaired a
couple of them
so can we assume that this is going to
uh
be an equivalent workload
um I might just
talk about dhrs which is probably the
least Pleasant aspect of any Council of
Duty I think you will know that from
your previous experience we currently
have 12 live dhrs running at the moment
not not in the Stratford District but
but across Warwickshire which is way way
above what the forecast was going to be
we
um
if that same level runs with serious
violence we will have this very
significant workload to pick that up uh
clearly it is
well I can't predict how and when it
arises but county lines is probably a
contributor towards serious violence
um and we now know all those numbers of
county lines has reduced from a height
of 23 at one point a few years ago
um
like a number of different business
models you get consolidation and bigger
and um
dare I say it more effective and more
efficient
operators coming in who've taken out
small players so
um it is going to be I think it's a
challenging task that we have to pick up
but we have no option but to pick it up
yes I think it was just worth uh logging
that it may well over time uh lead to a
fairly significant workload Council
adjunied and then counselor
behind me um speaking on behalf of some
of the experience I've got
um when the um the the serious violence
Duty was first consulted upon the local
government Association responded on
behalf of councils across the country
and they particular took a particular
point of view which actually coincided
with um the experience I've got with the
setting of a volster youth project
it emphasized
um the particular bit that they
emphasized was the way in which
prevention due to prevention can play
such an important particularly with
young people
but in their response to government at
the time they drew attention to several
things that for example
um that Children's Services faced a
massive cut at 3.1 billion funding cut
by 2025 that councils were being forced
to cut spending on local Youth Services
no can
can could I
could I forbear because I'm just saying
that this was the the reason why a youth
service in Ulster was set up there was a
particular
um this is the local government
Association
paper they were talking drawing
attention
well hang on a minute
I'm not sure this is directly relevant
counselor unit it is from the local
government Association nevertheless I'm
not sure I was going to put an offer to
see whether I could possibly help
they when the experience was that there
was a considerable cut in youth services
so we set up Ulster youth project at
that time
to try to raise money we have raised
money we raise money for the Hopkins
Precinct youth um player fairly recently
and one of the things we've just just
been granted from the police and crime
commissioner is a grant to work with
Ulster Town Council on exactly the what
you are talking about in that case
councilor junid can I just say that we
will bring my services and our services
for that role we understand your offer
of services and as we move through we
will take you up on that but thank you
uh councilor Crump do you wish to
comment at all
yeah thank you Mr I do apologize for the
for the picture on page 27 of the report
uh um yeah it's a for those of us
sensitive disposition just to see my
picture there it's a rather unfortunate
but uh if that puts people off crime it
might be it might be one benefit
um certainly I know where from the
County Council point of view
um the lead officer is is really well
respected and Warwickshire is netting
Porter of crime
the county lines come into Warwickshire
from all parts of several counties
particularly from from the West Midlands
area
and Warwickshire is working with uh with
the West Midlands in particular and
um Mr toy who's leading on this is uh is
is one of the leads and it's been asked
to do some things in the West Midlands
um
I know it's good that we're actually is
working with the county with the
districts and Brewers and as part of
that they have bid for safer streets
money from the government and there was
I think it's about 354 000 over the next
18 months for all parts of all parts of
the county apart from
um one which didn't help out a bit but I
know Stratford has got some money
Stratford district has got some money
for this so it's all part of a process
of working together the strategy in The
Proposal approach will have a positive
impact I believe in relation to
safeguarding and preventing violence
especially amongst those with protected
characteristics who do need Extra
Protection so
I think it's a really good paper both
from the county I'm from the district so
obviously with my twin hats I can see
both so
um some great work we do need support
and we need commitment and support from
all councilors of all parties uh and I
do think that um it can be tackled but
as councilor Kettle said you know there
are some disturbing parts of this
domestic homicides
um and several murders there was one
person who killed called two people uh
not too long ago sorry three people not
too long ago and uh including one
um not too far away so we've got to work
together on this and I think this is a
really good paper so thank you
thank you for your perspectives uh
councilor Council Harvey my apologies
thank you Mr Jim
um
without in any sense wishing to be
flippant
um this could be regarded as a
motherhood and apple pie sort of paper
because I don't know anybody who would
be in favor of uh violent crime
but if the if the district council is
going to play its part it needs to have
the resource to be able to do it what I
haven't heard yet is
um is the additional responsibilities
that been given to local authorities in
our case can it be resourced from
existing budgets can it be resourced
from within the staff levels or is there
a need for additional resource in order
for Stratford to play its full part in
this initiative
I think that's an excellent question
councilor Harvey I also noticed that
183 were the officers police and crime
commissioner uh
has
214 pounds to distribute but that is
over only three years and one does
wonder whether or not uh the end of
three years that money will disappear I
think the funding of this and the
resourcing of this is an issue that we
may need to return to particularly given
the discussion we had earlier on the
domestic homicide reviews and the amount
of workload those generate
so I think we will be very mindful of
that going forward
Mr Grafton
you may have spotted that technically
this paper is mine
anyway aside from that point I've been
listening with great interest to the
contributions
um so just to answer your questions
1.8.4 of the report bullet point four
three in fact
the refers to funding a dedicated
county-wide lead officer to support all
the specific Partners to meet the duty
so that is something that Warwickshire
County Council will be doing if you turn
over the page
um
to
1.8.6 you can see that what's being
identified there is the word burden in
other words it's a new burden so there
will be funding to deliver that yes
and it kind of can interject
we're sometimes put in this position of
having to effectively having to agree to
something which I'm all in favor of but
but we're effectively signing a blank
check nobody I I I understand the
references Mr grafton's made to to the
paper but I've yet to hear is it two
staff is it 10 staff is it half million
pounds what is it and until I know that
I'm going to feel uneasy about putting
my putting my vote in favor of this
I think at the moment the reality
probably is that we don't know councilor
Harvey councilor Kettle
um it would be very nice to believe we
have an option not to take this up but
it is actually a statute of
responsibility that has been
um set down for the benefit of district
councils and therefore it is something
over which we have no control clearly
um we will be waiting for the review LED
I assume by Jonathan toy uh at the
county who is extremely experienced
officer in these matters and it's
already doing an awful lot of work with
uh Karen Stanley and her team
um here
um Sam is representing her I assume
um
yes it is a blank check but what we do
know is we don't know the scale of the
investigations we will have to be
involved in but I mean if you think a
DHR will involve probably
20 parties
ballpark figure probation Health mental
health all those different people police
Etc
um and a document comes out which is at
the end of the day per DHR can be
something like 40 50 60 pages long uh
just the creation of that and the work
behind it is very extensive
and the worst case we will be doing
exactly the same
as what we're doing for DHR
um if there is an incident that falls
within the Stratford District so yes
there will be a very significant budget
but it's not something we can duck we
have to face up to it it's a legal
responsibility and I'm sure Council
Harvey with you all Della couldn't very
prudent approach to finance he will have
you'll have a something in your
piggyback hopefully for it if we need it
indeed can I just say that it has been
pointed out to me previously that there
are ways and ways of fulfilling
statutory obligations
Council adjunied
the things also that the
LGA Drew attention to was working you
know collectively and collaboratively
and it did say that when the in one of
the responses to to government that
support for writing funding bids could
be very helpful to communities and
Community organizations uh particularly
where they're you know you're working
with volunteers I suggest that um given
that we're not quite sure about where
the money is maybe we could help because
a lot of these communities actually do
have uh the ability to find find grants
and I I know that that's been helpful in
Austin I'm just wondering whether that's
something we could develop you may well
need to look at that counselor Junior
but picking up the point that you made
Mr Grafton if this is a new burden then
would one would expect some new burden
funding to be associated with it and I
think we just need to monitor very
closely exactly what that is
so I see no further hands wanting
comments so can I move to the
recommendations
on page nine there are three recommended
sorry two recommendations to Cabinet can
I have your agreement to those
recommendations members of cabinet
and we are to recommend to counsel the
other two recommendations on page nine
kind of have your agreement to those
please members of cabinet
thank you members of cabinets are moving
swiftly on uh there's nothing on Part D
cabinet committees they unblock items uh
are for noting so can we note uh the
cabinet work program the climate change
panel minutes the member development
working group minutes and the
stratford-uponhaven market Forum minutes
I assume there was a noted
so uh other matters there is just one
thing I would like to say and as this is
the last cabinet meeting of this Council
I would actually like to thank all
members of cabinet and all the members
sitting around this table at the moment
and the officers for the support they
have actually given over the last four
years I think it is fair to observe that
the last four years have not been
without their challenges to put it
mildly
uh we've had to cope with kovid the cost
of living crisis and the challenges seem
just to keep on coming
I have to say that I suspect the people
sitting around this table in a few
months time May well find that the next
four years bring
similar scale of challenges so can I
just thank everyone for the work they've
done thank everyone for the efforts
they've put in and the participation we
have had around the table which I think
has been absolutely excellent so can I
just say from my perspective thank you
to everyone in this room at the moment
so there'll be no urge in business